yes yes
yes welcome thank you very much great
show tonight
one of my favorites jb smoove gonna be
on the program tonight he is always
hilarious
and that sound of one man clapping
andy richter how are you andy hi conan
how are you
i'm doing really well it's nice to see
you from this safe distance
yes it is it's good it's it's uh
it's as per your contract yeah yeah yeah
going back to 1993 by the way correct
this is correct
this is the way i've wanted it long long
before covid
how are you old chum i'm good how are
you it's been a while
it has been a while but uh i really love
that we're here in this theater i love
being in a theater
it just gives me the sense that we're
getting closer to show business
yes you know we're not really there yet
but we're in a theater right and we're
closer
it's like public access like it's not
exactly
tv but it is kind of tv
okay okay i'm gonna be honest with you
that bummed me out
oh that really bummed me out i'm sorry i
mean
that's kind of what i do though i know
it's true
andy richter depressing conan since
september of 93.
[Laughter]
hey speaking of uh we got to talk about
this uh last night
i i announce that i wanted to fill my
audience here at the largo theater
with cardboard cutouts of fans just like
uh
major league baseball was doing so uh to
get an idea of what that would be like i
had our prop
department uh go into uh storage at
warner brothers and find
every random cardboard cutout they could
find
and they brought in the strangest
selection but we put them in the
audience we've got
ruth bader ginsburg right there we have
conrad bane from different strokes the
dad on different strokes
we have a life-size six foot six cut out
of former fbi director
james comey um i think he's either
taking the oath of office
or uh very formally trying to catch a
baseball
i don't know what's happening there and
then we've got four count em for
kevin hart's i think we bought those in
bulk
andy what do you think of our audience
right there i think it's great
i i love that how they're all to actual
scale uh here's what i've decided to do
i want to fill the rest of the audience
with
actual cardboard cutouts of our real
fans who are watching at home that's
right you can be sitting in my audience
we'll make a cardboard cutout of you
all you have to do is go to teamcoco.com
cutouts upload a photo of yourself
and you may be able to join our audience
in cardboard cutout form isn't this a
great idea andy it is a great idea
yeah we got to be making some money off
it right we're charging people like this
no
i didn't it's too late i didn't think of
that i should have thought of a way to
make this into a money
money making scheme i didn't do that
this is free uh
but if you send us your photos listen
people are already doing it
we announced this yesterday already
5 000 people seriously 5 000 people
have uh requested and sent in photos so
keep sending those
photos in you can be part of our
audience
and here's the other thing you i would
love it if you're
if your picture was laughing doesn't
have to
i get it i've seen this show
if you're not thrilled you can
you know be frowning or maybe just
checking out a little bit
you know it's your decision on what kind
of photograph you want to have we want
it to be realistic
and i would say andy you're often
scoping out the crowd a good
third of the crowd usually not thrilled
yeah well a lot of them don't speak
english they're here like
tour group i don't know how it's like we
get they're just they're very easy to
get
yes you can give them a bottle of water
and an orange and there's
that we are technically the wrong spot
we are technically a sanctuary
show people come here for sanctuary and
immunity
from being deported yes it's us and the
price is right we're the two shows that
people
that people flock to yeah and you do not
come on down on our show all right
seriously
you can do this uh send us your photo
and uh
you will be sitting in our audience and
you get to see yourself
and that's all the photos be clothing
optional
i think i want to avoid legal trouble
i'm going to say
photo it's the photos should be clothing
mandatory for now
and then we may we'll see how long uh
this quarantine goes on
maybe the clothes will come off at some
point all right yeah because we haven't
had nudes in the audience since like
early 90s
95 was the last one yeah yeah yeah it
was a hygiene thing
it was a hygiene thing and yeah we had
to steam clean the seats every
it was we i did well you
did i can't i'm the host of the show i
know i know you remember
that was the opinion thing big part of
your job early on